يأخذني أليخاندرو
في جولة في سيارته المكشوفة 54 شيفي ، ورسمها
باللون الوردي اللامع يقول
لجذب انتباه
العملاء المحتملين ، يكسب سائق مثل أليجاندرو
30 ساعة أكثر مما يكسبه بعض موظفي
الحكومة الكوبية
في شهر واحد يقود السياح حول
هافانا  في هذه الأيام في هافانا ،
لا يوجد أي سائح ،
لا أحد يقول إنه لا توجد
أرباح من السياحة الصفرية ،
ولم يعتقد أحد أن الأمر سيستمر طويلًا
في أوائل أبريل
بعد أن تم إحضار الحالات الأولى من فيروس كورونا
في كوبا من قبل
السياح ، وأغلقت كوبا الحدود الدولية
للسياحة.
توقف أحد ركائز الاقتصاد الكوبي بشكل صارخ في يوم من الأيام كانت مليئة
بالزوار
الساحات القديمة التي يبلغ عمرها 400 عام في هافانا القديمة الآن ، حيث
يتم تطويق الفنادق الجديدة تمامًا التي بنتها الحكومة الكوبية ، والتي تم
تصويرها على هافانا ، والتي تظهر
الشوارع الفارغة التي لا نهاية لها من خلال اتخاذ تدابير متطرفة
مثل
الإغلاق  تمكنت كوبا الحدودية الدولية
من الحفاظ
على عدد حالات الإصابة بالفيروس التاجي المؤكدة
منخفضًا نسبيًا مقارنة بالكثير
من بقية المنطقة ،
لكننا رأينا أنه عندما
تبدأ الحكومة في رفع هذه
القيود ،
فإن الأرقام تعود إلى الظهور
حتى الآن ، لا توجد أي معلومات حول موعد
إعادة فتح كوبا إلى بقية
العالم
في يوليو ، فتحت كوبا حفنة
الفنادق المملوكة للحكومة في المفاتيح المعزولة
حيث لا يتواصل الزوار الدوليون إلا
مع موظفي الفنادق ،
وقد زار عدد قليل من السياح الجزيرة حتى الآن ،
ولا يزال الكوبيون الذين يمتلكون المطاعم ويستأجرون منازلهم يترنحون حتى الآن
بسبب الحظر
الأمريكي وزيادة عقوبات الإدارة الرابحة.
أشهر
مع أرباح قليلة أو معدومة
يكافح الناس حقًا ، لكن بطريقة ما
يستمر الناس في التعامل مع الكازينوهات
الخاصة بمطاعم المنازل المستأجرة ، يبدو أن
الناس في الغالب
يستوعبون ويحاولون التمسك بها
حتى يكون هناك افتتاح مرة أخرى ،
يقول أليخاندرو الكلاسيكي  أصبحت سيارات مثله من
الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض على الطريق هنا لأن
معظم السائقين لا يستطيعون تحمل تكلفة البنزين
أو الحفاظ عليه  سيارات eir ، إنه يرسم
آماله
في لقاح تطوره كوبا ،
وآمل أن ينهي أطبائنا
اللقاح ويطعمون
كل شخص يقوله ويمكننا الذهاب إلى
الوضع الطبيعي الجديد لأن الأمور
لن تعود إلى طبيعتها حتى ذلك الحين
كوبا والكوبيون  سوف تضطر إلى الانتظار
للانضمام إلى بقية العالم
باتريك جوتمان سي إن هافانا